Today I decided I needed a break.
I'm in a funk. I do not feel motivated to get our school work done,
so we're just gonna not do it.
Next week was already a scheduled week off
before we jump in for the new school year,
so why not take an extra few days off?
The beauty of year round schooling is that when we get in these moods,
or particularly me, I get in these moods,
can take time off to refresh.
I do my kids a disservice when I'm trying to teach
from a point of frustration anyway,
so it's just better for all of us.
So for the next week, I'm gonna get together with friends,
read lots of books, do things that I enjoy,
to get myself in a good headspace before we start again on August 5th.